big changes ahead for one of the key
metrics for getting into college the
s.a.t exam is going completely digital
and will be shortened from three hours
down to two now a couple of things will
stay the same there's a verbal section
and a math section and a perfect score
will still be sixteen hundred but bottom
line this is another major change to a
test that has become well less essential
for getting admitted into college since
the pandemic began there's clearly a lot
at stake for students their families and
educational institutions so we've asked
priscilla rodriguez from the college
board the non-profit group that
administers the s.a.t as well as high
school junior natalia kasia to join us
priscilla let's start with you because
this goes beyond putting the current sat
on a digital platform i know you've said
that the college board is really taking
advantage of what delivering an
assessment digitally makes possible what
do you mean by that
well first thanks for having me um and
what we mean by that is by taking the
sat digital there are a number of
student and educator centered benefits
and improvements we're able to make so
i'll give you a few examples one you
cited the test will be shorter so from
three hours currently to about two hours
students will be able to get their
results back faster which is really
important for them as they make
decisions about college and and their
post high school plans
and we're going to be able to be way
more flexible with high schools who give
the sat to their students and that's
really important i just want to stress a
point here which is that 60
of all students who take the sat now
take it through our program called sat
school day so this is a program where a
school a district or even an entire
state pays for their students usually
juniors to take the sat free of charge
to the students
in the school building during the school
day this is huge for access and equity
but it's a paper and pencil test that
has to circle the globe and go to
millions of students and has to be
really secure we've had to be quite
rigid in how and when schools can give
school day this completely changes that
they're going to get to decide the day
the time how to group their students and
we think this will be a real boon for
again that access and equity the chance
to take the sat for every student
regardless of their background well
natalia is a student who took this test
natalia you participated in the november
global pilot of this new test tell me
what it was like for you what did you
notice about some of the key differences
did it seem easier harder how did you
take the test give me give me the
lowdown
hello so
i felt like the test was a lot more
shorter especially and concise
um
the questions at hand were a lot shorter
and i felt like i felt as though i could
answer the questions a lot faster than
the
written portion of the s.a.t
and you'll be applying to colleges next
year because you're a junior right now
i'm just wondering what do you think
will be
the major factor in determining whether
you'll submit your scores
um it honestly really
um it not only depends on my sat score
but it depends um
i guess
what i want to do
and um
i guess everything i'm doing right now
kind of determines where i'm going to go
i feel like that could really help
well going back to you priscilla i want
to talk about the changes to the sat
this is the third major overhaul of the
sat in the past 20 years during that
time it seems that in some cases the sat
has become a bit less relevant 1800
schools have made the test optional
including harvard
what specifically about these changes
make the test more relevant to those
universities that have said we're not
even really going to look at this score
and determining who gets to come to our
school
a few things i'll say on that the first
is we we're always listening and
learning both to students and again the
school's food ministry administer the
sat and going digital is going to allow
us to address so much of what they've
been telling us over the years so that's
this is really the next step in that
evolution when it comes to colleges and
we've been engaging with them as we've
been preparing for these changes
they tell us that the sat is still and
continues to be a vital part of their
holistic admissions process right it's
one piece of what they're looking at as
they look at students and so in a world
that is largely test optional as it is
today right and that that was really
spurred by the pandemic
we are focused on making the sat the
best possible option for students like
natalia right we want it to be
less stressful
a shorter test day
a
more clear measure of the core reading
writing and math skills that are
necessary for readiness for college and
importantly writing this for career and
when colleges view sat scores in context
right so they consider where a student
lives where a student learns it helps
them find students they otherwise may
not have i lived that personally
i'm first generation american my parents
moved to the u.s with very little by way
of financial resources and the psat and
the sat were what opened my eyes and my
mind to what could be possible and they
are what allowed colleges and
scholarship organizations to reach out
to me ones that i never thought would be
interested in a student like me that's
true for millions of students every year
so test optional allows students to take
the test see how they did decide if they
want to practice and try again if
they're happy and want to submit the
score or if they ultimately choose to
not submit the score um and it's
powerful and i think it's really
important that we preserve that choice
students want it 83 of students we
survey have consistently told us they
want the option to submit their score
and so that's the reason natalia why i
asked you what'll make you determine
whether to submit the scores or not
because clearly as a junior you don't
have a lot of time on your hands you
have to pick between extracurricular
activity or studying for your existing
tests or studying for a standardized
test i know that
this is around the time that you would
normally be taking the sat or act uh
spring of junior year is coming up
what are you hearing from your friends
how are you preparing for this exam
knowing that
in two years it could be very different
given that the sat is going digital and
more schools are choosing to go test
optional
um i see that as a good thing honestly
in two years from now i feel like
students will have the option to take um
i guess a better approach for them if
they'd like um
but knowing that i'd probably be missing
out is kind of sad
so yeah yeah natalia i'm curious i
remember in scarlet and i talk about our
personal high school experiences all the
time because it is so traumatic so my
heart is with you um i put a lot of
pressure on myself because i kind of
felt like the score i got my s.a.t would
determine whether i could afford college
a lot of the scholarships i applied to
only you know looked at students who had
a certain number for example
are you
putting that pressure on yourself for a
high sat score or does it feel like
given some of the changes that we've
talked about today does that number feel
like less of a consequential factor in
determining your education future
yeah given in today's world right now
knowing that sat scores are now optional
in some colleges
um and that more options are being
provided i feel as though i'm
like less stressed about my future and
what i can achieve
um
but it still puts emphasis on what i can
do versus um what may like what i may
have trouble in for example so that
makes sense another thing that we should
point out is that the uh digital sat
goes public in the u.s in 2024 but it
goes digital outside the us in 2023 so
priscilla i'm curious why there are
different rollouts and i wonder whether
over time the sat will become a more
valuable tool for evaluating
international students rather than
students inside the u.s like natalia
because
internationally provides some kind of
standard lens by which to judge through
which to judge
students from different backgrounds
that really is the power of the sat
overall so certainly internationally it
does exactly that right for us colleges
and universities who may not know high
schools in all these different countries
they can again they can see and find
these really talented students who want
to come to the us for college but the
same is true within the us there are 25
000 high schools in this country they
all have different course offerings and
grading policies so again where a
student feels that their test score is a
good reflection of what they know and
what they can do and they put it forward
in their application we hear from
colleges and they're they're saying it
publicly to students and families too
that's a really helpful and useful data
point for them to put next to high
school gpa next to whatever activities
students may be involved in and so again
that's really where we're focused on
making sure that the sat is the best
possible the least stressful option it
can be and that we make it available
anywhere and everywhere a student wants
that option i hear what you're saying
but at the same time will it become less
relevant to domestic students like
natalie who are applying to colleges in
the u.s and where the college admissions
directors might know a little bit more
about her school for instance
county high school in south county high
school in virginia than opposed to as
opposed to a high school in
venezuela for instance
there i'll say they're i mean what the
data is showing us so far right two
years in but what the data is showing us
so far is not only as i mentioned 83
percent of students say they they want
the option to put that score forward um
but also
um millions of students are still taking
the sat right it's been optional for two
years in fact more students in the class
of 2022 so their seniors now have taken
it than last year's class the numbers
are going up that is partly of course as
schools and communities have found ways
to reopen
throughout covid but it speaks to
students desire
to show what they know and what they can
do and with test optional the power is
really in their hands right to decide if
they want to put it forward or not and
that's again where i view our
responsibility
let's give students the best tool
to show what they know what they can do
and then they'll make a great decision
for themselves with their families and
with the teachers and adults around them
oh i'm looking at student philly and
bubbles and it's giving me ptsd i know
i'm so glad that the the students of
today i guess don't have to deal with
that for the digital option priscilla
final quick question for you to excel in
the test you've got to prep right and
ideally you're able to pay for a tutor
of course not everyone can do that and
not even everyone can afford the test
books right the prep books rather is the
move to digital an effort to address
some of the inequality that is a natural
part of the standardized test practice
so back in 2015 we developed a
partnership with another non-profit khan
academy
and we developed
the first ever free personalized online
digital sat practice called official sat
practice on khan academy so that was
2015. since then it has become the
number one way that students prepare for
the sat period
more than combining all paid test prep
and we did that for exactly the reasons
you mentioned
we don't there shouldn't be inequities
and practiced in preparation for the sat
it's a test of the core reading writing
and math skills that students learn in
high school but there was there was
inequity in access i experienced it
personally as a student i couldn't take
classes that
my peers were taking i also couldn't buy
the book i checked it out from my local
library i remember that viscerally and
this partnership with khan academy which
continues through this transition and in
fact we're going to make free
full-length digital sat practice tests
available on the digital testing
application that students will use so
they can actually simulate test day full
test on the test player yeah and and
that's really again that commitment to
making it possible for every student to
feel confident when they walk in really
appreciate you sharing that priscilla
thank you so much it reminds me i ended
up on sat prep tick tock last night so i
guess there are always new options for
learning and prepping for this s t prep
tick tock that is a new one i had not
heard of it priscilla rodriguez really
appreciate it vice president of college
readiness assessments at the college
board and of course natalie ocasio
student from south county high school in
lorton virginia good luck to you for the
rest of the year thank you both so much